[Music]
in 2001 a real world exercise tested the
emergency response to a bioterror attack
on the continental United States
[Music]
the operation was called Dark winter
within just a few days the simulation
spiraled out of control the operation
predicted a rapid breakdown in essential
institutions civil disorder and massive
civilian casualties
dark winter has revealed how vulnerable
we've become
our lifestyle our security our safety
depends on a delicate and unstable
economy
we've created a system so complicated
that we no longer understand how to
control it
oil power shipping transport we live in
a complex world
and the more complex it gets
the more fragile it becomes
the system is built on a global supply
chain that gets things where they're
needed just in time
created a house of cards
remove just one and everything falls
apart and what's fueling the system
money
[Music]
following Black Friday retail's busiest
day of the year a number of people began
getting sick and it was spreading
incredibly quickly
initially the symptoms were mistaken for
a severe case of the flu
however when people started dying from
it medical personnel quickly began
investigating and eventually discovered
that it seemed to be an outbreak of the
previously eradicated smallpox virus
to combat the outbreak the smallpox
vaccine was distributed to the public
but unfortunately the vaccine was
quickly proven ineffective and
devastatingly things were about to get a
whole lot worse
the city's infrastructure was starting
to break down hospitals were becoming
overloaded and the New York police force
was struggling to maintain the peace
a number of gangs of rioters were
starting to carve out their own
territories within the city
eventually the government assembled a
new line of defense hoping to help
maintain order this group was composed
of the police firefighters civil
Volunteers in the National Guard and
they were known as The Joint Task Force
day job to stop the spread of the virus
and uphold order within the city
the plan was simple all known infected
individuals would be relocated to the
center of the city separate from the
uninfected and in order to stop these
people from leaving and mixing with the
public a large wall would be built
around the quarantine area
this way the spirit would be contained
and they would be in a better position
to get the appropriate personnel and
bring them in directly to where the help
was needed
but eventually the situation got worse
and more than what the jgf could handle
one of the private military contractors
brought in to help keep the peace known
as The Last Man Battalion cut ties with
the jtf and started taking control of
parts of the city for themselves
and on top of this there were a number
of other hostile factions starting to
rise like the cleaners and the escaped
convicts known as the Rikers
this is when the first wave of Strategic
Homeland division agents were activated
their goal to assist the jtf and regain
control of the city
unfortunately it was too late
shortly after the first wave division
agents were released into the dark Zone
the government and the jtf pulled out
leaving behind suppliers medicine
weapons thousands of infected and the
first wave agents
abandoned and cut off from the outside
world many agents succumbed to the virus
or were killed by the growing hostile
factions within the quarantine Zone the
area that would later be known as the
dark Zone
the first wave of division agents were
labeled as Mia and presumed did
as a result this is the event that
triggered the second wave to be
activated
their goal was to investigate what
happened to the first wave and assist
the jtf in restoring order to New York
City
the Commander in charge along with the
majority of the second wave agents were
being flown in by helicopter to assemble
themselves just outside the Hostile Zone
but as they landed they were struck by
an inbound missile which caused the
helicopter to crash killing everyone on
board
it was now down to just a handful of
remaining shd agents to carry out the
mission
foreign
New York City was in a horrific State
and there were a number of rumors on how
the rest of the world wasn't doing too
much better either
hostile factions have sectioned off part
of the city fighting for territory there
were the Rikers who had escaped from the
prison on Rikers Island
they took advantage of the dwindling
prison staff who were either sick or no
longer turning up to work
once on the mainland their goal was to
wreak as much Havoc as possible on
society the society that had them locked
away especially authority figures like
the jtf
other groups weren't necessarily born
out of hate
the cleaners came about with the best of
intentions
they were among the thousands of
civilians left behind in the dark Zone
when the jgf pulled out
these were the workers that were helping
the jdf and keeping the city
infrastructure ticking along
construction workers sanitation janitors
garbagemen truck drivers
they were also heavily involved with the
construction of the quarantine's own
wall
but when the jtf suddenly picked up and
left
these civilians decided to take it upon
themselves to do what was needed to
contain the virus and restore order to
the streets of New York
and the way they decided to do this was
to burn everything that had been in
contact with the virus
contaminated items the bodies of those
who had died in anyone living that may
have become infected
the lmb or last man Battalion are a
private military contractor made up of
U.S military veterans
they were hired by large Wall Street
companies wanting to protect their
assets
the lmb worked alongside the jtf to
start with But as time went on they
watched the city go from bed to worse
sick of the indecisive local authorities
and the government's complete lack of
ability to control the situation the lmb
decided it was up to them to restore
order to the city
they broke their contract and cut ties
with the jtf executing an officer in the
process
from here they proceeded to do what they
deemed necessary to rectify the
situation at hand
second wave agents eventually found that
the source of the virus outbreak came
from New York Department Store Ables and
that the main responsible was a Dr
Gordon Amherst
their mission was now to locate Amherst
and find out what he knows in order to
develop a cure
however the second wave was also about
to make another Revelation as it was
discovered that the first wave agents
weren't all dead
in fact a lot of them were very much
alive and now working against the
government
they had gone Rogue
after the government pulled out of the
quarantine Zone the first wave agents
were unhappy with how things had been
handled by the jtf and the government
and this is where we're introduced to a
prominent figure in the division
storyline Aaron Keener
Aaron Kina was a first wave agent who
after the abandonment of the quarantine
Zone became disillusioned with the
government its plan to save the city and
his role within the division
Kina disavowed the division and went
rogue his first action after turning
against the government was to recruit
other first wave agents into his new
focus of survival and Power
any agents that refused were killed
causing other agents to cut
Communications and go into hiding
after forming his group of Rogue agents
Kina made up with the commanding officer
of the last man battalion
they agree to collaborate through a deal
that will benefit them both
Kina wanted to use the lmb to assist in
operations to establish dominance over
Manhattan and The lmb Wanted access to
the division shd technology to gain
advantage over the other hostile groups
Kina with the lmb launched many
operations against the opposing groups
including the jdf
the most notable one being an attack on
a helicopter that was carrying a
division Commander that was in charge of
the second wave of division agents
during his time working with the lmb
Kino was also investigating the virus
outbreak
he found that Dr Gordon Amherst was
responsible
kina's investigation led him to Dr
Vitali tradenko in the Russian consulate
who was also researching the virus
he organized some of his Rogue agents to
kidnap tranenko and his research
Kina then found Amber's lab as well as
some virus samples a 3D printer an
Amherst notes
his plan is to use trunenko and the
samples to weaponize the virus and use
it to fulfill his belief that only those
who are smart enough and good enough
survive
the old rules laws and governments are
gone
now only Power and survival matter
[Music]
it was at this time that Amherst was
found shortly after the outbreak it was
discovered that Amherst had fallen to
his own creation notes and recordings
detailed why he did it
his reason for creating and spreading
the virus was that Humanity was too
powerful on a global scale and that
mother nature needed a help in advancing
her creations
mankind is the greatest threat to the
survival of the planet through their own
greed but he had the Cure
Amherst also had a darwinist point of
view Only the Strong deserved to live
and his creation is the tool to ensure
that this happens
but at the same time he is willing and
accepted that his death may come from
his own creation
he was able to modify the basic smallpox
virus by combining it with several other
dangerous diseases like Ebola an H1N1 on
top of this he also modified the genetic
traits that controlled the incubation
period and made it so that it could
spread even while it was incubating in
the host
this made it particularly lethal Because
by the time that the host was showing
symptoms it had already spread to a
significant number of others
using a protein printer Amherst was able
to create the final form of his virus
just in time for Black Friday his plan
was to spread his new virus via means
that were most handled during the
shopping holiday money
hence the name the dollar flew
slowly the second wave division agents
in the jtf were able to push back the
Hostile factions and regain control of
the city the Rikers and cleaner
leadership was taken care of crippling
their advances
the lmb were pushed back to their final
stronghold located in the United Nations
building
during the lengthy battle Hina betrays
the lnb and escapes with trinica and his
fellow Rogue agents
the lmb is left to slowly be taken apart
by the division agents
it was later discovered that Kina had
spent some time on the westside Pier
at this stage all hostile groups had
feuds against him most of all the lmb
he broadcasted his location to bring all
hostile factions to this area to hunt
him down which in turn brought the jtf
and the division whose distraction
helped keep the Hostile groups from
finding him
he also taunted the division agents
stating that no one will ever find him
and despite the quarantines and
lockdowns of the island he'll soon be
gone
it's now confirmed that Aaron Kina is
long gone from Manhattan and New York
City altogether
there is confirmation that Kina is or
was in Washington DC but he continues to
leave messages for the jtf and other
government agents to convince the
mother's ways and beliefs and to join
him and his agents in working against
the government
his final message was to inform the
division that his eyes had not just set
on the United States but now the world
seven months have passed since the green
poison outbreak and the events that
unfolded in New York City division
agents had continued on with their
mission of saving what remains across
the United States
when suddenly their Lifeline was sivered
the shd network the backbone of their
advanced technology and Communications
goes dead
quickly followed by the backup protocol
of a distress call that summons all
agents to the nation's capital
Washington DC
from outside of DC make their way to the
capital
fighting through the city they come
across what remains of the city's Joint
Task Force who have set up their base of
operations in the White House
shd coordinators on site fill in the
agents on what is happening throughout
the city
three hostile factions are fighting for
control
the hyenas a group that is composed of
several gangs who have come together as
one under the leadership of a council to
take advantage of the chaos that is
unfolding
the outcasts a group made up of the
survivors from the Roosevelt Island
quarantine Zone
their goal to enact revenge on those
responsible for their mistreatment and
to the society that allowed it to happen
and the true Sons
a powerful group of xjtf who have lost
faith in the government's ability to
bring control to the situation at hand
the division agents get to work finding
the fault to restore the shd network but
before they can achieve this new
information comes to light
somewhere in the city there may in fact
be a cure to the virus that started it
all but also that the previously assumed
dead president Ellis may have survived
the crash of Air Force One
while clearing out the areas throughout
the city the agents find Intel on else's
whereabouts and that he's being held
captive by the hyenas
the division managed to clear the
hostiles and extract them via helicopter
back at the White House Ellis confirms
that there is a vector cure but not just
for the green poison but all viral
infections
however is unable to access it without
his briefcase if this was on Air Force
One when it went down
the briefcase was in position of the
true sons and they were holding it in
their HQ at the U.S Capitol building
president Ellis ordered the agents to do
what it takes to cleanse the city of
this hostile forces and return his
briefcase
however the division wasn't strong
enough to be able to tackle this
challenge just yet
those things first they located The
Fault in the network and restored power
to the shd and their agents
from here they sit forth clearing the
hostiles and pushing them back to their
respective strongholds
upon removing the hyenas from the
district Union Arena the outcasts from
Roosevelt Island and then the true sons
from the U.S Capitol building the
division had now eliminated all hostile
leadership leaving the factions in a
state of disarray but also they had
Alice's briefcase
while the agents in the jtf celebrated
their progress towards regaining control
of the capital a force that had been
looking in the shadows suddenly made
themselves known
the technologically advanced private
military company called The Black Tusk
launched a full invasion of the city
landmarks and strategic points
throughout the city were quickly brought
under black trust control and it was
during this time that President Ellis
suddenly disappeared
it was revealed that the black task had
been watching the progress of the dollar
flu outbreak for some time including the
actions of the shd
division agents found out that it was
this new hostile force that was
responsible for the shd network being
taken down and that they had been
planning this Invasion since the
outbreak first occurred
the black task head in very quick
succession completely undone all of the
progress that the division had made up
until now
and wavered the Agents Against All Odds
once again fought through
it was discovered that President Ellis
had actually handed over the antivirus
to the black task and that they had been
working together and in fact had
something to do with the death of the
last president they had him put into
power
the antivirus were being held to the
Black Tusk Tidal Basin headquarters
the agents launched an attack and
managed to fight through the
technologically Superior forces
regaining control of the antivirus
Washington DC is once again in a state
of Mayhem with the three hostile
factions although without their original
leaders fighting for control
and a Now new more powerful faction
attempting to establish a new Dynasty to
lead the country and to a new era
president Ellis has been located he is
found to be hiding out at the
presidential Retreat Camp White Oak
under heavy guard by black task forces
the jtf and the division Assault The
Compound in an attempt to arrest Alice
and bring him back for questioning
unfortunately before they could reach
him he managed to escape
his whereabouts are currently unknown
the division agents then turned their
attention to the Pentagon they have
received a transmission from an agent
close by
it was scouting the dark elapse to see
if they'd succeeded in developing a
profusion bioreactor
with this device they will be able to
produce large quantities of the broad
spectrum antivirals and start to
distribute them across the population
however they weren't the only ones
looking for it
a large black task operation was
underway they were attempting to dig
down through the Pentagon and extract
the bioreactor
but the division agents managed to put a
stop to this in turn killing dozens of
black task officers
the perfusion bioreactor is now being
kept at the White House along with the
broad spectrum antivirals
the next step towards creating the Cure
requires the agents to find someone
capable of running such an undertaking
someone with experience in this field
the division receives Intel on the
whereabouts of a former agent who is at
the top of their most wanted list
Aaron Keener has finally resurfaced
after disappearing months ago last seen
in New York City
has made a deal with the Black Tusk unit
that is stationed on Coney Island
is planning on trading vitelli trinenko
in exchange for a favor that will call
upon at a later date
traninko's virologist that had ties to
the creator of the dollar flew Gordon
Amherst
the division saw this as a great
opportunity
Kina is The Man Behind countless deaths
of jtf and shd agents and the leader of
the initial rogue agent uprising
entrenenko would be the perfect
candidate to run the bioreactor
the situation was too good to slip by
aware they could be running into a trap
the division launched an operation to
rescue tranenko and capture Kina
despite heavy Black Tusk presence they
managed to extract the Russian scientist
to this surprise an old foe had joined
the fight the cleaners
the Black Tusk suffered heavy losses at
the hands of both the cleaners and the
division agents
they were forced to retreat
striscoll was received from the division
command in lower Manhattan City Hall has
been attacked
Agents from Washington DC make their way
to New York
through video surveillance it is found
that a group of Rogues led by Aaron
Keener were the ones responsible
the attack left the building completely
destroyed and contaminated by a new
unknown virus that Kina had acquired
from Vitali dronenko before they parted
ways
the hunt for arenkina was on
[Music]
division Agents set up a base in a local
settlement called haven
where the local commanding agent bailau
got to work compiling Clues on kina's
whereabouts
with all that had happened over the last
few months in New York with the
countless once loyal agents going rogue
faith in the division was at an all-time
low
agents would have to regain the trust of
the remaining population if they were to
succeed
one by one the agents located and
eliminated kina's Rogue lieutenants
through each encounter they found new
Clues and Intel on keena's whereabouts
including his plans to reset Society
keynote set himself up on Liberty Island
his plan was to launch a ballistic
missile that was filled with his new
weaponized virus on Manhattan
the agents bought a theory and make
their way to Liberty Island but before
they make it there they're attacked by
the Black Tusk who have also learned of
kina's location and are trying to get to
him before the division does they sent
Ground Forces to stop Keener including a
marauder-class quadcopter warhounds and
a Razorback missile launcher but the
division agents managed to push through
and overwhelm their forces
it was now just the agents and Kina
even with his new more advanced shd Tech
Kino is no match for the division agents
they managed to destroy the missile
launcher containing the virus in heavily
wound Kina
he escaped to the pier but his injuries
proved too much
the division agents caught up to him and
before they could stop him he activated
something on his watch something he
called his legacy
with his dying breaths he laughed at the
agents telling them that they have no
idea what's coming
before dying shortly after
it was at this time broadcasted through
kina's watch that the division
discovered that the acting commander of
the division in New York feylau had gone
Rogue and was working with the Black
Tusk
before kina's death he had organized an
attack on Washington DC rogue agent
Jupiter was given the task of carrying
this out
Jupiter assembled her team of Rogue
agents and equipped them with the new
rogue Network smart watches the agent
Theo Parnell had developed alongside
Kina
while on Mission Jupiter would receive a
package keynote Sentra sample of his new
weaponized Eclipse virus
both Kina now out of the picture she had
it disposed of
to her this operation was about getting
rid of the virus not spreading something
far more dangerous
Jupiter and the Rogues have teamed up
with the cleaners for this mission
she informs them of multiple reports of
experiments being carried out to
weaponize the virus in DC it makes it
very clear that the goal is to eradicate
the green poison and anyone who could be
spreading it
following the path of Destruction
division agents would eventually catch
up with Jupiter's Rogues and take them
out one by one
it was discovered that Jupiter was on
Roosevelt Island uncovering a newly
developed EMP technology from a cargo
plane that had crashed there some time
ago
this tick was capable of neutralizing
all non-road Network shd Tech including
the agent's armor
her plan was to recover all the tick and
dispatch it out to Rogue agents
Nationwide rendering the division
completely helpless
by the time division agents caught up
with the the cleaners had set up a solid
foothold on the island and were
preparing to use it as a staging point
for the emission of cleansing Washington
DC of the virus by burning it to the
ground
but the agents were too much for them
the cleaners were pushed back
even after Jupiter had them utilize the
new EMP gems against them they fought
through killing the cleaners the emps
and eventually Jupiter
rogue agent Hornet had history with Kina
they served together in the U.S army
long before they were recruited by the
division
Hornet saw them as brothers and would do
anything that was asked of them
during Keno's attack on lower main
hidden he gave Hornet some of the
eclipse virus along with instructions of
how to create more
on top of this he tasked Hornet with
going to Washington DC along with four
other Rogue agents to recruit members to
his cause
the outcasts were the most likely
solution as they were currently without
a leader and in need of a purpose
but Hornet's Rogue agents weren't
exactly the most subtle in their
movements division agents had no problem
tracking them down and eliminating them
eventually exposing his location a Tidal
Basin
Hornet to the space to organize his new
Outcast recruits and get a supplies of
eclipse virus moved out of the city
but the agents were pushing through the
compound too quickly
Hornet attempted to slow them down by
releasing some of the virus around the
base
however it was too late the agents were
able to clear the outcast forces and
then haunt it in a stockpile of eclipse
virus
black tusk's specialist leader Barden
Schaefer has been tasked with working
alongside the recently turned Rogue they
Lao
she has provided him with full Rogue
agents but he is having his doubts and
shares his concerns with Black Tusk
leader Natalia Sokolova
but Natalia shakes it off saying that
this is an opportunity for Fey and a
Rogues to prove their worth as well as
keeping a business partners happy
Georges Schaefer to handle the
responsibility as it was him who brought
Faye to the black task in the first
place
during the operation Sheffer continued
to receive unreasonable requests from
these Rogue agents until he eventually
decided it was time to contact feilau
they would end up organizing a meeting
on Coney Island to discuss the operation
and growing expenses
in the meantime chaffer's Rogues are
being hunted down by the division with
the assistance of someone or something
that refuses to stop and talk and
instead opts to disappear after each
encounter
from the outside the Schaefer and Fey
meeting appeared as a setup to kill Faye
but regardless of what it was intended
to be used for the shd agents would soon
crash the party before anything was able
to go down they would invade Coney
Island rapidly working their way through
the Rikers stationed there and meet face
to face with the entity that was
responsible for helping with hunting
down the Rogue agents this asset or
operative would be taken down by the
agents but he seemed to be known by
Shafer in Natalya in fact he seemed to
be working with them
the agents would turn their attention to
Schaefer after engaging with some of the
most elite btsu in their ranks agents
were able to catch up with them and
after a short fire fight chafer would
become severely wounded
Kelso would send in a team to retrieve
an apprehend him
agents finally discover Intel on
feylau's whereabouts given her
prominence within the agency her actions
in turning her back on the division make
him more than just another rogue agent
Target
for the agents this is personal
after taking down a team of Rogues they
would find out that she is at Camp White
Oak with President Ellis
but by the time the agents get there
they has assassinated Ellis and is
attempting to escape the compound via
helicopter
blaming the division for Alice's death
she is surrounded by a large contingent
of black task forces
before she is able to leave the agents
catch up with her and disable the
transport
they is now forced to engage in a fight
against the agents she once worked so
closely with
they would eventually be killed by the
agents but after a death they would
discover that not everything was what it
seemed
audio logs left by Faye would explain
that everything she has been doing is
for the greater good of the division in
the country
her plan was to gain trust within the
Black Tusk and work her way up through
their ranks to put herself into a
position where she could take them apart
from the inside and her first Target was
President Ellis
she needed everything to look authentic
it needed to appear as if she was just
another agent defecting from the
division
so for this reason she couldn't let
anyone know what she was doing
on top of this she was working closely
with bud and Shafer who had lost faith
in the direction the Black Tusk was
headed
as Natalia's number one man in the btsu
he holds a large amount of Intel from
what Natalya and her partners are
planning
but for now he is still in a coma from
his engagement with the division at the
end of season three
when the jtf was assembled in Washington
DC Captain Lewis would be placed under
the command of Colonel Antoine Ridgeway
when Ridgeway stopped taking orders from
above and started taking matters into
his own hands Lewis was one of the
soldiers who would stay loyal to his
cause rebranding themselves as the true
Sons
after ridgway's death at the hands of
the division General Anderson would take
the reins
Anderson would eventually have Lewis
carry out an operation in DC they were
hunting for something and have now found
it
Lewis and his men head to the Jefferson
Trade Center immediately and this is
where the division would catch up with
them
except he is all alone the last member
of his team
Lewis would explain that there is
something much louder at play here in
regardless of their differences they
should team up to bring it down
although they don't necessarily trust
him the agents agree
the division along with Lewis get to
work taking down the Black Tusk who have
taken hold of the site
while in there Lewis warns the agents
that the btsu are not the biggest threat
present on site there is something far
more dangerous something he calls the
recruiter
agents eventually take down the Black
Tusk forces
the recruiter having done nothing to
observe from a distance throughout the
fight would vanish shortly after
however to add to this confusion the
agents would also find out that the
Black Tusk soldier who is commanding
this operation had an agent watch on him
with Isaac detecting an agent status
the agents pushed Lewis for answers but
he would simply tell them to get in
contact with them when they had finally
caught up with what was happening around
them
this operation also reveals and confirms
the cooperation between Natalia Sokolova
and Kelvin McManus
McManus turns out to be the Secretary of
Homeland Security and that he is his own
personal unit of covert special
operatives known to us as the hunters
being Homeland Security McManus is not
only aware of the shd from its very
early days but is somewhat responsible
for them
following the mission at Jefferson Trade
Center General Anderson has come to the
realization that the true sons are no
match for the division or the Black Tusk
so as reached out to Natalia Sokolova in
an attempt to team up
Natalia sends out a team of Black Tusk
operatives to assist and work out the
viability of this new potential Alliance
however in the background many and Lewis
have been communicating
prior to more recent events many and
Lewis worked alongside each other in the
jtf all the way up until the day that
Colonel Antoine Ridgeway turned his back
on the government after losing faith in
their ability to do what was needed to
make it through this pandemic
the jtf around Ridgeway were faced with
the choice to fall back to other jtf
units or to join his new band calling
themselves the true sons in turn
becoming an enemy of the country
many fell back keeping to his oath while
Lewis sided with the Bridgeway agreeing
that things needed to be done
differently if the country was going to
survive
however now after ridgeway's death
although Lewis still feels that what he
did was justified under Anderson things
have now changed and he wants to help
put a stop to Anderson and Natalia's
plans
he's managed to find at least 100 True
Sons so far who are willing to follow
him and team up with the division to
take Anderson down
but unfortunately for him Anderson and
Natalya are on to him and have been
watching for a while waiting and
preparing to see how this plays out
after the division had finished dealing
with Natalia's Black Tusk operatives who
were sent to assist the true Sons
agents would discover General Anderson's
location at the pintco Fairview power
plant where he had a meeting planned
with Natalia Sokolova
but he isn't the only one there
other than the hordes of Black Tusk
Natalia and Anderson have now acted on
their suspicions around Captain Lewis
so Lewis and his men have now been
captured
this mission is now more than just about
apprehending General Anderson
this is a rescue mission
the soldiers that Captain Lewis had been
preparing for transfer over to the
division had been rounded up and either
locked away or executed
running through various challenges
including EMP Jammers that were set up
in the laboratory and Rising steam
pressure in the cooling tower agents
would make their way to the reactor
there laws have been locked away in an
office while btsu operatives activated a
Fail-Safe setting the building on fire
after deactivating the fire suppression
system
division agents were successful in
turning on the valves and reactivating
the sprinklers rescuing Lewis in the
process but with little warning Lewis
took off in pursuit of Anderson
however Anderson had already made it to
the docks when Natalia had arrived with
hovercrafts
the agents would meet up with Lewis in
the parking lot where a helicopter was
waiting to extract them
agent Kelso to Captain Lewis
go for Lewis
negative the black husk have the general
I'll send a team to intercept nah
negative
it's not worth the risk
there's a fleet of a black house
only made points
affected
thank you and your boys for the assist
I look forward to working with you now
that we're Partners she looked like the
president of the PTA
details
now there is the slight pickup that the
division took the plant
but I'm not concerned they've most
likely moved on to their next assignment
she raises
we'll regroup and take back what is
rightfully ours
and
my true sons are at your disposal and
ready to follow your orders excellent
let's get to work
so this is a somewhat summarized picture
of the division story as of the end of
year four in the division two
but for anyone interested in more detail
I have links to many other videos in the
description
I'm actually still working on a full
detailed video around the story but this
is sitting at around four to five hours
long and I'm far from finished so with
other projects going on I have no idea
how long this will take me to complete
although the division have managed to
stop a number of the blacktosk
operations and have captured or killed a
lot of their leadership up until this
point it has barely slowed their
movements and then there is the
organization behind the btsu being led
by Natalia Sokolova while the black
tasks have all the troops on the ground
it is this organization who is calling
the shots
the division themselves are in a bad
place at the moment most of the Regents
have either been killed or have turned
Rogue
those who still remain loyal to the shd
May too be flagged as Rogue after the
assassination of the president who up
until this point was one of the last
remaining officials of the Old
Government
and then there is Kelvin McManus his
hunters and Barton Schaefer who may have
all the information the division needs
to push forward but as of now he's still
in a coma
year 5 is looking pretty good with
another two games coming out they could
be feeding into the overarching story
from a couple of different angles
before I go a big thank you to all of my
channel and patreon members anyone
familiar with the channel will know that
I don't do a particularly good job of
pandering to YouTube and its rules as
they often hinder the creative Direction
I like to take so I often find my videos
being demonetized age blocked and
heavily restricted
your above and beyond support definitely
keeps the channel alive
from my family and I I thank you very
much
otherwise I hope everyone enjoyed this
video and extremist malice extremely
remedial
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]